Speaker 1: Let's go next to let's go to schizo
from North Carolina. Schizo, you're on the air.
Speaker 2: Can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 2: Awesome. I had a
question. So in one of your episodes
and on May 3rd you were talking about
Esper withholding information to make
money on a book. And you mentioned something
you had talked about, you know, agreeing with
conservatism. Could you explain exactly what
that what that what you mean by that and.
I'm not a conservative. I'm just kind
of wondering what your opinion is on it.
Speaker 1: You're saying, what? Like, why am I not
a conservative? You're saying that's the question?
Speaker 2: No. You so you said you
had you disagree with conservatism.
Speaker 1: I'm not a conservative. Yeah, I don't
agree with conservative ideas. I'm a progressive,
but, I mean, are you saying, like, I'm not sure.
Speaker 2: I wasn't particularly because what you
were talking about, you said something that.
The whole aspect. So the point you made was
that Esper was basically like, you could say
that what he did, withholding that information
being treasonous. And I agree with that. That's
an interesting point. And then you had said that
this isn't conservatism. You would disagree with
conservatism. And my question is like, what is
what is it about conservatism that you disagree
with apart from, you know, being a progressive?
Speaker 1: Oh, I guess you're asking me my
political philosophy. I mean, I disagree with
the economic ideas of the of conservatism, and I
disagree with the social ideas of conservatism.
I think the economic ideas have been debunked
empirically, and I think the social ideas are
retrograde, antiquated and completely the opposite
of of modernity. I mean, I don't know I don't know
if I can lay out on every issue, my political
philosophy, but like my entire show is based
on the idea that I'm a progressive. And I think
that those conservative ideas are bad and are
bad for the country and bad for the people.
Speaker 2: Okay. Understood. Yeah, because I
finding myself to be more progressive, I've never
felt or been aligned with conservatism. I was just
curious because my awakening from like political
awakening was 2020. And I voted for Biden
because at the time I didn't really understand
political politics and stuff like that. But I
voted for Biden because Trump just seemed like
not the best choice. And I'm finding myself that
that was the best choice for 2020. But I'm fine.
Speaker 1: Which was which was the best
choice for 2020. But okay. Okay. And how
old were you in 2020?
Speaker 2: I was 28.
Speaker 1: Wow. So you didn't you
could have voted in 2016 and you
could have voted in 2012, but you didn't.
Speaker 2: Right. And there's a bit of a
backstory that obviously I'm not going to go into
for the time. But yeah, at the time I'm so sorry
I voted for Biden. And one of the other things I
wanted to ask or I guess kind of like tell you was
the interviews that you've been having with
Republican candidates. I've been enjoying a lot
and not from like a laughing at them for still not
accepting like that gut check question where who
is currently the president of the U.S. and they
will just dance around. And I love it because.
It makes me it's kind of like you're not trying
to directly attack that person, but the people
who are watching can kind of see, hey, this is the
idea that these people are having. And it sort of
gets the people to kind of like think about why do
they think that way? And the reason why I've been
enjoying that is because I am currently surrounded
by a lot of conservative Republican people
who I don't think understand conservatism.
And what they're doing is they're just kind
of repeating the talking points and believing the
conspiracies, and they don't really have a good
basis for their their their political views. Well,
that's very common. Right. And I guess that's sort
of my point is why you disagree with it, because
I kind of wanted your take on it because I
I'm still like in that journey where I'm trying
to understand, you know, politics in that way.
Speaker 1: Got it. Well, listen, I lay out all
my political views on my show. Any clip you find,
that's me laying out my political
views. So schizo from North Carolina,
I very much appreciate the call. I am going
to move on because I've got a bunch of other
people here waiting. Let's go next to Daniel from
Texas. Daniel, welcome. What's on your mind today?
Speaker 2: And David hear me?
Speaker 1: Just barely. Daniel, what's going on?
Speaker 2: So I'll tell you in
closing, I know I was just a.
Sorry. And Jamil this morning,
though. I'm from Texas, as I says,
but I've been looking at a lot of the races
around the country. And one the ones I'm also
most interested in seeing the outcome of is
Louisiana's Senate race with Gary Chambers.
I was wondering what your thoughts might
be about him, whether you think he has he
has a chance to win and his platform and all that?
Speaker 1: You know, I don't really know that much
about that race. That's not one of the ones
I've been following super closely. But it seemed
this to be to be accurate. This is the race in
which the incumbent is the Republican Senator,
John Kennedy, who's cuckoo for Cocoa Puffs. And
then you've got Gary Chambers and then there's
a couple of other candidates as well. Right.
So it's like a nonpartisan election that's
done there. It's a bit of a different system.
Speaker 2: Yeah, kind of from what I've been
able to figure out. Like basically I guess I'm
going to be running at the same time. Yeah. With
Changerooms being like just under the income
and the other two kind of like the way. Yeah.
Speaker 1: Yeah. It looks like they had their
primary on November 8th and then it looks like the
top two will go to sort of like the final election
on December 10th. Yeah. Listen, I don't know much
about Gary Chambers. I know that John Kennedy is
a disaster. So, I mean, I it would be improper
for me to say I support Chambers only because he's
not Kennedy, because I don't really know anything
about him. But Kennedy is not a good guy, and I
support removing him. But I'd have to look more
into the race to be able to say any more about it.
Speaker 2: Okay? Yeah.
Speaker 1: Oh, boy. All right, now we're losing
you. Daniel, the connection is going haywire,
so I'm going to let you go. Let's
go next to. Why don't we go to Bobby
from Jersey? Bobby, welcome to the show.
Speaker 2: Hello? David, could you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 2: Okay. My question is, is that
what do you think drives people to arrive at their
political conclusions? Do you think it's more of
a biological or environmental reasons that make
the debate them draw to that specific conclusion?
Speaker 1: So there's a couple different things
going on here. This is a great question. One,
in general, people's political views do mirror
those of their parents and the community they were
raised in and the people they were raised around.
So there is no question that there is lots of
people who if you put them in a liberal family in
Connecticut, they're likely to end up liberal. If
you put them in a conservative family in Arkansas,
they're more likely to end up conservative. So one
part of it is the environment you grow up around.
At the same time, there are some pretty good peer
reviewed studies into the differences in brains
between left and right wingers, and it's believed
that right wingers have stronger sort of like
disgust reactions and fear reactions, and that
that also appears to be a factor. So it's kind of
a boring answer, but it appears to be sort of like
a combination of all of these different things.
Speaker 2: So that was actually kind of the
answer I was looking for because I've run
into stuff like that and I noticed many of
the different personality traits between
me and many of my conservative colleagues.
Speaker 1: Oh, what do you get?
What's an example? What's a trait
you notice in your conservative colleagues?
Speaker 2: Like a lot of them tend to be very
aggressive. They tend to always want more.
They always. They're very status obsessed.
Very hard to say. Interesting. Yeah. So I that's
that's something I've noticed. Thank you, David.
Speaker 1: All right. There's Bobby from
Jersey with a nice, nice question. That's
a good topic. Yeah, there's there's a lot of
science around that, and not everybody sort of,
like, accepts or likes it or agrees with the
science, but it's pretty interesting stuff.